[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous souvenez vous du temps où enfin
vous jouiez avec des avions de papier la
vie paraissait plus simple à cette
époque là non j'ai pas vous mais moi je
passais tout mon temps avec les amis a
essayé on découvrait par une chose on
s'invente des histoires remplies des
jeux ont passé des journées à faire ça
notre critère premier pour faire ces
choix là en fait non notre seul critère
pour faire des choix à l'époque c'était
le briser si c'était amusant on
continuer si ce n'est pas amusant ont
changé on notait en rajouter au combiné
laissés à nous mêmes on pensait de
journée complète à découvrir notre
univers
un immédiat qui sans s'en rendre compte
on apprenait on apprenait sur cet
univers là
puis on apprenait sur soi on apprenait
entre nous je prends vraiment plus
fondamentalement fondamentale louis
fondamental encore on apprenait à
apprendre le bon vieux temps en fait
j'ai pas qu'est ce qui est advenu de
votre petit garçon de votre petit et moi
mon petit gars je les temps ci en
vieillissant migrants vers la vie adulte
mais je les refoulés dans un petit coin
assez creux pour faire place à d'autres
choses comme la performance l'efficacité
l' expertise tout des choses très utile
dans la vie adulte évidemment puis
peut-être parce qu'ils étaient plus avec
moi mais il ya comme un équilibre qui
s'est perdue que d'autres traits qui ont
émergé d'être un petit peu moins
intéressant que vous connaissez
peut-être comme la peur de faire des
erreurs
elle a peur du ridicule légaux qui dit
mon dieu qu'est-ce que mon patron va pas
si ce n'est pas la solution
parce que mes collègues vont dire ce que
je perds mon emploi mais bon il faut
croire que c'est le prix à payer pour
être performant dans la vie
professionnelle ou c'était peut-être le
prix à payer jusqu'à récemment
mais je pense ce qui est sûr c'est que
celui de moins en moins c'est de moins
en moins vrai
de moins en moins vrai parce que comme
vous savez le monde change le monde
s'accélère on interagit plus entre nous
on communique plus plus rapidement plus
globalement qu'on le faisait avant et de
ce fait la grande planète sans
rapetisser en génère plus d'informations
de d'atr en une année que toutes les
années avant on a accès à plus
d'informations
et pourtant on a autant d'incertitudes
en bref on pourrait dire que le monde se
complexifie je vous entends vous allez
me voir mais jeff la complexité ce pas
nouveau ça existe depuis toujours
vous avez raison la complexité existe
depuis que le monde est monde depuis le
big bang change cependant ce qui change
c'est le rythme auquel nous à être
humain nous devons y faire face
ce c'est vrai qu'ils vous soyez kouagou
facile
que vous soyez un par un étudiant
ingénieur un entrepreneur président
compagnie vous faites face au quotidien
à plus de complexité cave comme toujours
dans ces histoires là il ya une bonne et
une mauvaise nouvelle la mauvaise
nouvelle c'est qu'on est pas super bien
équipé pour faire face à la complexité
on n'a pas appris la bonne nouvelle
c'est que la clé pour être confortable
dans la complexité
vous l'avez déjà elle est déjà en vue
mais avant de regarder c'est quoi cette
les là encore faudrait-il qu'on en parle
c'est quoi la complexité qu'est ce que
ça veut dire un problème complexe
mais si vous le voulez bien me prendre
quelques instants pour démystifier la
complexité on va regarder les problèmes
complexes qu'on va les mettre à côté de
ses petits frères des problèmes conflit
qui plie problèmes simples et pour
garder tout ça mais on va le mettre sur
une bonne vieille grille de deux par
deux puisqu'on vous puis moi je pense
qu'on peut tout expliquer dans le monde
avec une grille de départ
prête à y va sur l' axe horizontal
vous avez le niveau d'interaction sur
l'axé vertical vous avez les niveaux
d'incertitude deux mots vous connaissez
bien peut-être un détail pour
l'interaction
ici on parle de toutes formes
d'interaction humaine est une machine à
machine humains hamashima système tout
des bonne interaction
donc si on a un faible niveau
d'interaction et un faible niveau
d'incertitude on est ce qu'on appelle un
problème simple c'est quoi un problème
simple j'ai soif une cruche d'eau une
verge version 1 dans l'autre je bois mon
problème résolu caractéristiques d'un
problème c'est sexy simple qu'est ce
qu'on veut dire par là on me dira que la
chaîne de causalité de cause à effet est
parfaitement clair et donc c'est aussi
facilement reproduisit bhl dernier petit
détail pour le simple faut pas confondre
simple avec simplice est insignifiant
les problèmes cinq sont une grosse
partie de notre quotidien
surtout quand vient le temps de parler
de qualité de performance de processus
si tous deux lors du problème simple ça
c'est pour le problème ça si on a
demandé une bonne interaction niveau
d'incertitude on tombe dans le problème
compliqué ça on est bon le compliqué on
est des champions on a appris à faire ça
c'est la résolution de problèmes mineurs
un exemple le problème compliqué ma la
construction d'une maison ou d'un
barrage caractéristiques d'un problème
compliqué première caractéristique
normalement le premier communiqué on
connaît le résultat final
avant même de commencer à preuve je peux
faire une maquette de maison ou de mon
garage avant même la première pelletée
de terre
deuxième caractéristique
normalement un problème compliqué à une
seule bonne solution
le barrage y retient l'eau où il retient
paulo n'est pas rentré deux points
barrages c'est comme une passoire
quand même affaire finalement les
problèmes compliqués ont des petites
poches l'inconnu on les voit on les
identifie on y met de côté donc par
exemple pour le barrage qui n'est
peut-être pas le type de sol sur la
rivière une fois qu'on va avoir détourné
le cours d'eau on va faire un test de
sol selon le résultat je vais adapter
par m
de construction alors que le problème
compliqué on connaît le résultat final
avant de commencer une bonne solution
des petites poches l'inconnu si on
augmente les niveaux d'interaction
niveau certaines incertitudes longtemps
dans le sujet qui nous préoccupe ce soir
les problèmes complexes
c'est quoi le problème complexe
je présume que ya une bonne partie
d'entre vous qui avez des enfants vous
vous levez la main si vous avez des
enfants vous avez fait une planification
stratégique de l'éducation de vos
enfants de 0 à 20 ans pourquoi vous
risque important des enfants faut
planifier son nom évidemment vous riez
parce que j'ose de complètement absurde
dans cette question-là faire une
planification stratégique de l'éducation
de mon enfance c'est vrai mais pas par
où commencer pour faire ça vous aurez
compris qu'il y avait un enfant si c'est
un problème sans ça il part donc
clairement pas un problème complexe
tout comme le réchauffement climatique
est un problème complexe
tout comme la pollution par le plastique
ou les files d'attentes interminables
aux urgences tout des problèmes
complexes caractéristiques d'un problème
complexe
contrairement au problème compliqué de
tout à l'heure on ne connaît pas le
résultat final
avant de commencer contrairement aussi
au problème compliqué il y a plus qu'une
bonne solution
et quelque part on en est tous un peu la
preuve ici ce soir je prend pour acquis
je devrais peut-être pas mais je prend
pour acquis qu'on est tous des adultes
relativement sain et équilibré
jeudi prenaient pour acquis et ce et ce
malgré le fait que nous parents nous a
tous élevés de façon complètement
différente les uns des autres
plus qu'une bonne solution et en
parallèle si vous avez le jour la joie
le bonheur le plaisir d'abord cinq
enfants et que vous les ayez exactement
tous la même façon il ne paraît trop
fine appareils vous l'aurez compris on
connaît pas le résultat final avant de
commencer et finalement ce lundi que
dans le problème compliqué il ya des
petites poches inconnu c'est la somme du
problème complexe qui au départ est
inconnue on connaît pas ce qu'on aime
pas dans le complexe mais non pour
terminer graphique si on veut au maximum
on augmente le niveau d'interaction et
des certitudes on tombe dans le chaos
c'est quoi le chaos
ballack a aussi la crise c'est quoi une
crise un tsunami
une inondation un avion qui rentre dans
une tour comme on a vu malheureusement
ya quelques années ça génère du câble
caractéristiques du chaos
bah c'est chaotique et lorsqu'on veut
dire par là c'est que la chaîne de
causalité le cause à effet cette fois ci
se désagrège complètement c'est pas en
gardant tout ce qui s'est passé une nuit
jusqu'à maintenant qu'on peut prédire ce
qui s'en vient et à l'inversé peu en
regardant au loin et qu'on peut déduire
ce qui s'est passé ailleurs
donc vous avez les quatre types de
problèmes ou de façon plus positive et
globale écart type d'environnement les
problèmes aux environnements simple les
problèmes mon environnement compliqué
complexe et critique mais non ce qui
nous intéresse aujourd'hui c'est savoir
comme un comportement complexe
donc on parle de confort on parle de
d'attitude de postures 2007
donc on va rajouter un verbe à chacun de
ces endroits là pour nous aider pour le
simple le verbe qui veulent lancer
catégoriser pourquoi parce qu'on le plus
étant donné que le niveau d'incertitude
est bas on travaille avec du connu
donc on va faire un nice une check list
puisqu'on a besoin pour le compliqué cet
égard du dispositif dont il faut
analyser l'image d'une belle image pour
le compliqué ça serait un diagramme de
gaines pour ceux qui font de la gestion
de projet va falloir licite et les
tâches oui mais il faut aussi voir
lesquels vont aller dans quel ordre
où sont les interdépendances entre
l'état et quel est le chemin critique
pour se rendre jusqu'au bout donc
analyser et le besoin pour le compliqué
maintenant je me souviens conflit
complexe que instants pour aller
directement au chaos qu'est ce qu'il
faut faire
en situation de crise je donne l indice
si l'édifice est en fait on fait quoi
demande à sa presse spots en le
catégoriser d'analysé de voir comment
qu'on se sent par rapport au feu c'est
comme tout le monde à une fois qu'on
soit dehors on aura le temps de faire ça
donc dans le chaos qu'est ce qu'il faut
faire il faut agir
c'est ça le vern qui va cette année la
foa j'ai pour essayer de se sortir de la
crise
maintenant le complexe si on dit que
dans une situation complexe
on ne connaît pas on est dans un inconnu
quoi faire pour avancer dans l'inconnu
mais on peut marcher à tâtons on peut
chercher creuser tester essayer tout
dépend finalement le verbe que je vous
propose ce soir ces sondes et on va
sonder certains comme une image qui me
viennent toujours en tête quand je pense
à ceux ci devraient du petit garçon
indiqué qu'ils découvrent une caverne en
r d chez lui chez eux après l'école et
avec les amis prend sa lampe de poche
puis mon voir qu'est-ce que dans la
cabine
il revient à la maison pour ce prix
après supprimant dans la chambre dessine
ce qu'ils ont vu le lendemain après
l'école on retourne dans la caverne avec
les amis on veut un petit peu plus loin
et on vient on dessine et ainsi de suite
on va sonder cette inconnue la de petit
à petit et de façon itérative une belle
image qui veulent pour le complexe c'est
la spirale la spirale qui pour moi
représente le processus itératif en
passant ceux d'entre vous qui sont en
affaires c'est explique pourquoi depuis
quelques années il ya des mots qui
reviennent toujours fameux besoin comme
le lignes design design thinking l'agile
kanban et c'est pourquoi parce que ce
sont aux les processus itératif qui
permet d'explorer un inconnu dauphin
donc si on dit que la posture à voir
dans le complexe en est une d'ouverture
de curiosité une volonté d'apprendre de
cette inconnue l'homme quoi faire pour
être confortable je vous ai dit tout à
l'heure que la clé du confort dans cette
complexité
vous l'aviez déjà elle était déjà en vue
en fait c'est pas tout à fait du goût
qui l'avait c'est l'enfant en vous qui
la possède alors la première étape pour
être confortable dans la complexité sera
peut-être pour vous ce qu'elle a été
pour moi dans les dernières années
c'est à dire de vous réconcilier avec
l'enfant va vous réconcilier puis le
laisser remonter à la surface pour
s'asseoir à côté de vous parce que la
prochaine fois que vous ferez face à un
problème complexe
maintenant que vous savez exactement
quoi faire pour les identifier
peut-être devriez-vous et ça c'est
l'étape numéro 2 faire confiance à
l'enfant et finalement 3e étape en
terminant 3e étape serait en fait une
étape
j'hésite un peu parce que moi même je
continue à travailler cette étape si on
dit que pour la complexité il faut avoir
cette ouverture et qui ont dit que avec
votre enfant vous l'avez référé faire
émerger à la surface
la troisième étape je vous la laisse
sous forme de question seriez vous prêt
la prochaine fois que vous ferez face à
un problème complexe d'aller jusqu'à
sincèrement vous laisser guider par la
faim à vous merci
[Applaudissements]